[Music]
joe
you are my ancient aliens brother oh
yeah
what about that show so you know how in
that show they talk about how our
ancestors
are manipulated from the aliens yeah or
like another
oh what do they call it the ancient
other worldly beer being
yeah the theories that we are the aliens
yeah we are
we came from other planets right well
it's kind of exciting because right now
we
just discovered like there's this new
study that came out that
it showed that it is possible for
uh bacteria to survive in outer space so
what they found
is this certain bacteria that survived
for three years
on the iss and the international space
station and so
that is giving um it's
pretty much like helping to confirm a
little bit
the theory that we also came
from outer space because there's this
theory um
so like some kind of alien where i chew
from mars and then they shot that
[ __ ] and it came to the earth
and
it colonized the earth with that
bacteria i think it's more of like the
idea of everybody came from bacteria
or but then um is it the one that like
can live in like lava and [ __ ]
yeah so this this bacteria they call it
like lava won't kill it
i said lava won't kill it i don't know
about the lava part but there's
the best of all time yeah but i don't
know nothing that will survive in lava
dude
well there's like different types of
bacteria and they're highly adaptive so
some can
uh survive in oxygen like low oxygen
environments
extreme heat environments extreme
chlorine environments
i saw like at the bottom sea floor where
it's close to the magmas
where uh they have the it's not
volcanoes but they have those gas
fart rockets that happen in the low low
low sea levels
and they didn't believe that sea
creatures could survive in such a hot
environment
or it's boiling water a ton there right
yeah they found like crabs and [ __ ] like
that
and i'm like man that sucks to be
reincarnated to that [ __ ]
but i would have never thought that
there would be any creature or anything
that can survive in lava
that's some [ __ ] dude lava yeah i know
these [ __ ] melted stones
what's crazier super cold ice like the
coldest it can be or
lava because it's burning it's fire like
how do you survive that's like
[ __ ] walking through fire going
and i'm a tony robbins seminar guy ah i
walk on the [ __ ] stones i don't give
a [ __ ]
but this but the but the ice though like
ice i don't know i just i feel like
you know there's like [ __ ] polar
bears you just get frozen
yeah or like a preserve you just kind of
chill like you're a caveman that just
died and [ __ ] and just
chilling yeah i remember the they were
called like tardigrades
or is this it tardigrades it's not it
starts with the
no they not the one that they're talking
about
but but they were saying though the
reason why they survived on the iss
is because the first layer of bacteria
on the surface
died and protected the deeper layers of
the bacteria
so it's just they're under a bunch of
dead bodies yeah and so
with that like knowing that it
it supports the panspermia theory
which is a hypothesis that i mentioned
earlier that life
exists throughout the universe that is
distributed by space dust
meteoroids asteroids comets and all
these things right so they're saying
that like these
out of like outer space items are coming
into the earth and
that's a theory that one like a comet
had a certain bacteria or sugar
particles that
sparked life on earth oh so that's what
they're saying
that was just jesus with a slingshot
going all right we're going to start
this [ __ ] oh
you know for him in the slingshot no
he's got like i don't know he got like i
don't know in this jesus world he's just
going to
do little life forms he's like all right
i made a [ __ ] like life rocket
yeah and then they're saying that with
this discovery
that now they're considering the fact
that bacteria could have made it to mars
with our rovers
so you know we've been sending [ __ ] to
mars so we've been contaminating the
spaces
maybe oh maybe we have contaminated mars
already i hope it's probiotics because
that's the good bacteria
yeah but it's pretty exciting and it
makes me think about ancient aliens
cause imagine like
the rover's been there for like 30 years
and then they go we found life on mars
not knowing that we [ __ ] brought life
to mars
and then it started evolving interesting
interesting isn't that crazy where like
because like you think they're the
smartest people in the world but then
they're also
kind of clumsy and like oh my god
there's a human hair here
what we brought this here you stupid
[ __ ]
[ __ ] years ago yeah that'd be so funny
like these humans on mars
it's like no they just didn't put their
hair in a bun and it came out
that's crazy because i've been watching
the um what are the prequels to the
alien series
um predator i don't know y'all know what
i'm talking about prometheus yeah
prometheus
oh yeah yeah yeah such good i hate like
horror movies thriller type movies and
stuff but this was just so interesting
because it feels like
is the sci-fi party real yeah the sci-fi
part of it feels like
it could probably happen oh yeah i
should get my girlfriend to watch it
then because she hates horror and stuff
too
right she's like you know interested
into
yeah the science stuff and there's some
like kind of crazy thriller moments
but i watched those on my own that's
really rare
to get me to watch like a horror movie
hell no i'm with you yeah it's just
scary we're just looking so
so we try to like muster up the courage
to be like nah today's the day and it's
both of us
and then we're like let's go on netflix
all right horror section
and then we start scrolling and looking
at movie three all right
and we look at the cover all right no
not even that so we look at the cover
art and we're like
we've seen enough go back rob like you
just see the saw guys face with the
[ __ ] red spirals you're like oh geez
i'm outta here
i'm out you're scared too yeah yeah but
i'm a little bit more
daring now where i like the feeling of
being scared
so i do want to watch mine is the after
like
dreaming about it yeah that's me dude
you can't sleep because you're thinking
about these
things and yeah so it's like an
overactive imagination type thing
being able to get a cup of water at 3am
and not imagine what's behind the
door or like taking out the trash and
you're running mind over matter guys
nah i can't do it i really can't do it
it's a problem my mind is going over
what's mattering right now oh no because
i can't
know like in the dark or whatever i get
[ __ ] scared right and i tell myself
there's nothing there there's nothing
there why are you scared
you're not scared and then i keep going
easy i wish i could do that
no i still haven't gotten uh you just
gotta add comedy to it right
if there was a ghost i pull my dick out
and say do you like this
and it goes goes away or they might stay
because they don't like it
no yeah the ghost probably seen it all i
know right
i don't know uh i i don't
go out of my way to look at horror
either but it's
yeah but i watch it if my friends do
sure but i never really
thought why it's just not one of those
genres like if i had to choose i'll be
like
sci-fi [ __ ] yeah or like
post-apocalyptic [ __ ] yeah i can't wait
to
watch it but then when a horror thing is
there i'm like
this is probably what's going to happen
if somebody's going to die a lot of them
are predictable
a lot of people get scared with
thrillers like thrill like people will
consider thrillers as horror genres
yeah those for me are more like group
activity movies like i've never
watched it by myself but i think it's
like all of us a thriller because it's
kind of fun everyone's kind of like
screaming at the loud noises yeah yeah
it is fun but like watching the buyers
because it's always this the plot's
always like
oh you hear that noise let's go see
what's over there so if you're watching
it by yourself
that's what that's what pisses me
they're so [ __ ] stupid why don't why
would i want to watch this it's so dumb
yeah let's
investigate the [ __ ] crazy thing
exactly
oh there's blood dripping to the door
what's going on over there [ __ ] off
yeah it's like it's like going chainsaw
better go check that out
it's like going through one of those
like scary mazes you know like you
wouldn't go through it alone because you
need to see your friends freak out
even if you might figure out whether you
go to escape room by yourself that means
you're a loser
i'm cool with the not scary farm type
mazes and stuff
you are the universal stuff like i do
enjoy it because it is a group activity
yeah
but something about the horror movies i
think i think movies
essentially it's like yeah that's part
of it it's like
everything in the movie from the start
to the end sets you up to believe that
you're like in that world if it's a good
movie
right yeah so that's why i get so
invested like you forget that you're in
this world
in a line you know and then you go in
yeah and you get to
leave you know what i mean kelly you
really invested your mind
is really like working 24 7.
in a movie i like the ones that have a
really good story though
because they kind of follow a format but
i'm specifically talking more like
slashers slashers are pretty boring to
me because it's pretty simple they're
gonna run and you know they're gonna
trip
yeah you're like [ __ ] why you why ever
run and then they're just like walking
too like the they never tell anyone
where they're going you know they're
like i'm just gonna go
and go into the forest not tell a single
person that i'm going stupid yeah and
they lose reception i know
but this isn't a i don't know if it's
considered horror but i mean like
psychological thrillers
i love the purge series what's that the
perch
the purge yeah they have i don't know if
it's really like a horror thriller
yeah but it's [ __ ] i like that um i
think because also the the
world is a very hypothetical situation
so you get to explore that space so yeah
imagine if there was a world like this i
think i like that kind of [ __ ]
how about um going back to this whole
thing though like does it
for you guys and your own like psyche
does it
would it change anything for you if if
this was confirmed like for effect
we we like humans came from outer space
or whatever like
i told you [ __ ] uh i think it would be
cool because then it open
then it's a confirmed possibility that
there is more
you know like rather than being like oh
i think there's more other life in the
universe it's like oh if we came from
something
that means there's a [ __ ] ton more out
there like guaranteed
so i think you would specifically look
for that yeah i already feel cause i
already have my own conclusions
we're really similar to a dolphin or
really similar to a pig or really
similar to a monkey
so in my my my in my own mind i already
feel like we're just a genetically
modified organism by someone else so i
already feel like we came from space or
there's
we don't even look natural that's
interesting that you would see it that
way because for me i see it as we are
the aliens because there's nothing
like us but we're very close to primates
though very very close that's why i'm
i really like this panspermia theory
because
it is just saying like the seed of our
creation
came from not of this planet and i i
agree with that
like and then all of like everything
else that is life in this planet came
from that seed
yeah and then like everything else got
like its own species and all this stuff
was just so interesting to me you know
like when you think about a human right
and you just even even like i guess
primitive or like hunter-gatherer humans
right
they still don't look like
we're not equipped like a like a monkey
is like just
that pops out of the [ __ ] monkey
[ __ ] and starts
living like we all have to learn
and like use all that stuff yeah we're
the only tools and everything
that are very vulnerable when we're born
and we could die like we need to be
taken care of like how the [ __ ] do we
survive
and we don't look natural to like we
don't look like a natural animal that
fits with the environment right that's
what i mean and stuff and all that stuff
has affected it through the years i'm
sure
but even yeah like you know tribes out
there that haven't had
human contact and they've been the same
for like thousands of years
i'm like why does this exist
nothing like a flamingo you look at a
naked human in nature it just looks
weird
it doesn't look right yeah you see like
a baby alligator get born right and
immediately when it slithers into like
the marsh
it's just like oh [ __ ] it's at its home
if you see like a [ __ ]
naked baby run in any environment grand
canyon or
yeah it would die it just looks why is
there a naked baby here just doesn't
look right
it doesn't fit anywhere my my theory is
that
it yeah we would be kind of foolish to
think that we're the only like species
like us
in just earth you know i feel like
science has proved there's so many
different galaxies and stuff and like
why wouldn't we
why would we think we're the only ones
you know it's such like a self-centering
view i feel like you know i do believe
in god i believe that he um
created i believe he created evolution
you know what i mean so i like believe
in science and all that stuff talk about
too i'm like i don't
i don't know why science and religion
are so like
yeah it doesn't have to they can coexist
i i believe that anyway
is that he probably did maybe create the
first species that
end up evolving and adapting and that's
why we have different races and stuff
because we're in different part of the
world but
i really don't think that we're the only
ones for sure
[Music]
you